міс тубон api на 10 вечора п'ятниці
поліцейські за зрозуміти образу кілька машин
і не пояснюй причини група ну і сварка
ну ти на паркування володіє rocher
посиленням али через скільки секунд
всі 100 і відразу мило з рутинний контроль
правоохоронців люб'язно зникають у
ідеям пройти перевірку на явний
тлумачну в крові так що відводь я реван
алкоголю в крові перевищуючи пив про мило
тим самим адміністративно порушення
а як щоб він відправив а це ж кримінально
справа авто audi на підживлення та тінішева
на пару шив завантажую штраф витку 300 до
3000 євро а також про позбавлення
прав водія терміном виду 2 до 3
місяців
а ви куляєте і на народити про вищого ти
навіки ременя у 0,3 проміле муразе
аварій алкоголю вожатим у кожного
обставлену вигляд проходячи пройти контроль
пофарбовані виду є берулава
вітрильника відро сідоною велику
поліцейську діліть там рекордера в нього
кров для аналізу потім складати акт
про 1 стор атомне право порушення абу
пруське не зло чину водички право
забирає навчивши нашу та знімаю групи 1
молодий до виду волосся відпочине і в
трубочку та зачини вася в машині
вище через до річки годину поліцейському
sevda лося в мовляв це її вийти з
автомобіля
а дівчина посадив і в патрульну машину
і ви ж злі до поліцейську ділите
ришта воді його волосся б мер але
проходили тест брав і трубочку на згадку
з пукін поїхав і дали кореспонденти у
ви вирішивши нас обидві пари вірить справність
про лад поліцейських як і чудово ну і
кома 0 ми на лузі руку через бояться на
дорогах негайно загнула близько 400
людей
цифра чимало особи у два з половиною рази
менше ні шиша 12 руки в тому не втомлююся
кермо груди без п'яних і водія ми адже
граємо і деш на психологічного
обстеження у народі його прозвали
тестом для ідіотів пройдіть на приймальню
процедуру потрібно тимково зловив і
вибуховим алкоголь у крові 1 тіла 60-их
проміле
обидва пак і а бухту повторно попався на
воді не розумні тварюки за мосту не поспішаю ми
на мага і мусі відразу метаючи до часто
патент у живий алкоголь прикладом cool їх
так скажемо вони явно галина п'ю від с у
мене було 1 і 7 прізвище цетше 100 в
підкові
я рубаю ви знов до такого на можна but i
у такі ситуації сестри за гормоном ожив
його
людський організм так навпаки головне
задач оводія і до справді поверну-то
собі право по раку нато психолога що за
корму вин більше п'яним несучи до озера
btc складно за словами або рядом валить
часто порушено кіно відразу складу та тест
для іде створюється і малюка строго бій
3 рази у крем з пилку ваня з психологом
потрібно пройти комп'ютерний тест на
реакцію так само ми дихаємо abs теж не
образиться така процедура в кра, що ми в
занепаду у 500 євро в їх шуму ok до тисяч а
цілою чорницею та суботу біля місця
виборах і стосуються зараз завжди багата
різновид виду voucher що думаєте він та про
пияцтво на дорогах і це нормально для
них випад і isis ти за корму 1 п взагалі
нормально а либишся в дружини можна
я не може бути і пиво і потім сюди то
за корму
алли думаю з на обличчі багата людою ці
скажуть він напиватися нічого класичного
ведунів до
гадаю одні за його нормально олег що
говорить і в село Муту ціни просто теми
нині багаті люду і вино кичі разів п'яних
за кормом просто трава знати про суми ж
шкір по фінансах ви вирішать і . жити без
шахта з пенні пу звинувачуєш а тобто
починаючи від і по автобану тобто але поки що
її до spooky ну ну а поліція буна тим
часом вид рапортувала про результати
рейду за них правоохоронці провернула
за напис тисяч його геїв і провели 142
тест на алкоголь три людини був і
добряка на пиття катування червона на біржі
лісовим по рушником ви зовсім засим на
воді машини відростять і вісімковий
людині кадpa varta вся додумав пиво на
четверту ранку на велосипеді у нього
реван алкоголю в крові складно тіла 56
про мила за приблизно цим висимо пляж про
його ти завантажую йому за рятуванням
рівного дені автомобілі